thank you for joining us today and
welcome to today's live broadcast the
molecular pathology perspective of the
CDC's infectious diseases pathology
branch I am Judy O'Rourke with lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events today's educational web seminars
presented my lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning this webinar is sponsored by
SIA x placing the power of life-changing
answers into the hands of those who care
everywhere for more information please
visit sigh XCOM before we start there
are a few instructions we want to hear
from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment answers are welcome
to and you can do this by hitting the
green two in a button at the lower left
of the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions we'll try to
get to as many as we can and we'll
follow up if we don't have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now let's get
right to today's presenter we are proud
to welcome dr. Amy M Dennison dr.
Dennison is a microbiologist in the
infectious diseases pathology branch of
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention the CDC in Atlanta Georgia
where she develops and performs
diagnostic assays to assess infectious
diseases in formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues much of her
work has focused on viral respiratory
diseases especially influenza as well as
tick-borne diseases like rickettsia
rickettsii as a postdoctoral fellow at
the CDC doctor Dennison study the
bacterium coxiella burnetii assessing
genomic variation between different
archive strains dr. jenison received her
PhD degree in molecular and cellular
pathology from the University of Alabama
and firming
now where she studied examined surface
protein variation in mycoplasma paul
mones i will now turn the presentation
over to dr. Denison thank you very much
Judy I appreciate the introduction and
I'm glad to be speaking with you all
today well today I'm going to give you a
little bit of background on what we do
here at the CDC and the infectious
diseases pathology branch and
specifically in the molecular pathology
team so if we go to the second slide
while many groups here at the CDC focus
on a specific pathogen or specific
related pathogens say the influenza
division or the briquette seals and Oh
Sees branch the things that tie us
together here in the infectious diseases
pathology branch are really the
pathology that we see in tissues and
whether there's an infectious disease
related process that we're seeing in
those so primarily what we look at is
autopsy tissues but occasionally we do
receive biopsies and surgical and
veterinary tissue specimens it's our
mission to provide support to state
health department's clinicians Medical
Examiner's pathologists international
collaborators as well as assist the
subject matter experts here at CDC in
investigations that are ongoing what we
really do the heart of our work is we
investigate outbreaks of and explain
etiology so the next slide gives you a
little idea of our specimens and the
submission process what we look for is
the process of an infectious disease in
the tissues as suggested by clinical
epidemiological and our pathological
findings so typically the clinician or
the medical examiner will see something
on histopathology of the tissues and
that will be suggestive an infectious
disease process again with the clinical
history typically sudden death without a
fever or a prodrome is probably not
going to be an infectious disease
process it's also helpful that we get
all the quick clinical information along
with these cases so that we have an idea
of exposure
history and any other lab findings that
were found if they were in the hospital
for any length of time the types of
tissue that we typically receive here
then we do get some non fixed frozen
tissues and those can be used for pcr
and for culture isolation often times
portions of those are then fixed in
formalin and are processed into paraffin
blocks however we can also receive just
formalin-fixed tissues or what they call
wet tissues but ideally those need to
have been in formalin for less than a
month we also will receive paraffin
blocks and we can do on those and you
know has the chemistry PCR as well as
electron microscopy unstained slides can
also be sent to us but we can only do
and you know history chemistry on those
we cannot do PCR or electron microscopy
if we receive other non tissue specimens
say blood or or CSF we typically will
share those with a specific subject
matter group here at CDC as needed
moving on to the next slide what happens
when we receive a specimen here in the
infectious diseases pathology brands we
accession those into a database so that
we have some control of the information
so we can keep the specimen clinical
information together along with what
types of samples we receive any fixed
issues that we get are then processed
into paraffin-embedded blocks and then
we will cut sections from those
paraffin-embedded blocks for histology
and hmes then are then viewed in sign
out which happens every day here in the
infectious diseases pathology branch and
based on the clinical history and what
is seen in those a Chinese special
stains immunohistochemistry testing as
well as molecular testing can then be
requested all of the testing we keep
track of an essential internal database
which helps the pathologist in the end
to assemble a report that isn't sent
back to the submitter when all of the
testing is complete
however formalin fixing these tissues
has its drawbacks when it comes to
molecular pathology so formal and
fixation and paraffin embedding results
in three things that are potentially
negative towards the nucleic acids
within the specimen one is oxidation the
air over time can affect and degrade the
nucleic acids in the sample in addition
formalin it fragments the nucleic acids
as well as cross-links and chemically
modifies the nucleic acids so to
exemplify that i have a slide here that
shows a gene sequence and it shows in
the very early portion of that gene
sequence the first fragment they say if
we have for bacteria total the first one
ends up having a fragment that's quite
short because of fragmentation due to
formalin if you see the yellow dot then
in the middle that's a DNA protein
cross-linked and what would be the third
bacteria and in the second we have
another fragmented portion that's shown
by the green line in the second bacteria
so of the four that we have only one of
them has an intact gene so you can see
here that due to this process we just
reduced our sensitivity to twenty-five
percent so we have a few techniques that
we can use to try to overcome those but
it is something that we have to be aware
of when we're working with these types
of tissues so moving to the next slide
this is slide 6 oxidation or just the
air affecting the samples this is going
to be something that happens over time
so older samples are more difficult to
obtain quality nucleic acids from but if
the specimen was fixed in formalin for a
short enough period of time we have been
able to examine decades old material and
gotten quite nice results from it some
of the factors that are involved in the
fragmentation cross-linking and chemical
modification as I just mentioned the
time in the ten percent neutral buffered
for
is really key we really like to see that
less than a month but really less than
two weeks is preferable we've had one
rare case that was positive for flu by
real-time rt-pcr after six months but
that is an extremely rare situation so
our recommendation is that after no more
than two weeks samples be transferred to
seventy percent ethanol so that they can
be stored longer-term elevated
temperatures during the embedding
process to create the formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue blocks can also
result in these negative factors as well
as we've seen the quality of formalin
there have been some countries that will
send us specimens and their formal and
have heavy metals or is impure and
results in our inability to get decent
nucleic acids from these tissues so how
do we go about extracting nucleic acids
from formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue well you can see here on the
right this is a picture of a tissue
block this is slide 7 and we use a
microtome two slots slice a 16
micrometer section from that and we put
that in an eppendorf tube we then remove
the paraffin using xylene and then wash
twice an ethanol and then dry the tissue
pellet and once it's dried and it needs
to be very dry that is we digest that
overnight and proteinase k and buffer
the next morning when we come in we have
an elevated heat step that we use for
RNA that's at 80 degrees Celsius for 15
minutes step and the DNA is a 70 degree
Celsius for ten minute steps and what
this does is not only in activating the
proteinase K but is also helping to
reverse some of that cross-linking the
overnight digestion is also part of that
process once that's done we use the
kyochon chemistry for DNA we have a kya
janu CP kit that we use to isolate the
DNA if we're going to do a real-time
rt-pcr assay for this we will then use
an easy one
robot that's made by kyochon in order to
extract the RNA but in certain
situations especially if we're doing
conventional rt-pcr we will still use a
traditional female core for method to
isolate RNA so moving on to slide 8 we
will quality control check all of the
nucleic acids that we are using the DNA
we will check with a multiplex PCR that
looks at both beta globin that's a 200
base pair fragment and gap pH which is a
500 base pair fragment and this gives us
an indication to the level of
fragmentation of the specimen that we
have so if we have something that's
positive for the 200 base pair but
negative for the 500 base pair we know
that any assays that we have developed
that are greater than 200 and base pairs
expected for the amplicon may not work
so we in the end may report out an
inadequate tissue specimen as a result
for RNA if the specimen is going to be
analyzed by real-time rt-pcr we use a
beta 2 microglobulin RNA specific
housekeeping assay that's 75 base pairs
or if we're using it in a conventional
rt-pcr we have an 18s rrna it's actually
a commercial kit that we use it's a 324
base pair si so when we actually are
then moving on to assessing for specific
pathogens that are found in these
tissues how do we go about designing
primers well what we want to do is look
for a region that's conserved but at the
same time it needs to contain enough
variability so that we can use Sanger
sequencing to differentiate it from
other say related viruses so if we were
looking at flaviviruses for example we
want conserved regions on the five prime
and three print ends where the primer is
a needle but in the middle when we get a
sequencing results we want to be able to
use the variation that's found in the
middle to find these specific flavivirus
if we can whether that be dengue or Zika
or something else we also want these
to not match human sequences if at all
possible or if it does match them it
means to be different enough in size
that when we run these on an agarose gel
we can size select what we're looking
for and excise that from the Jail we
also as a consequence of the level of
fragmentation look at very small
amplicons so we typically are going to
go less than five hundred base pairs if
at all possible when we design these
primer pairs so moving on to the next
slide slide nine there are some assays
that we do where we use real-time pcr or
real-time rt-pcr and some of these we
even have the ability to then run on an
agarose gel and sequence them so shown
here on this slide is just the overall
amplification plots from an influenza
run that i did recently and if we move
on to slide 10 these are the actual
results that show you sort of how the
plate is set up and we have six
different targets that we look at in row
a across the plate that's the
housekeeping control the beta 2
microglobulin housekeeping and we also
have in ro be a target for flu a and
Rosie a target for swine a and indie a
target for swine h1 and all four of
those taken together as you can see in
column 7 if all of those are positive
those are the key gene targets that are
needed to be positive in order to say
that that particular case is positive
for 2009 pandemic influenza a h1n1 we
also have targets for h3 as well as flu
be so we have a way to to check make
sure that we have multiple positives
here and can determine that we have good
quality nucleic acids and can say
whether we have a positive or negative
case for influenza and moving on to
slide 11 when we have to do conventional
pcr or real-time pcr we will run the
reaction and then run that on
Inauguration gel as i'm in
and we will then excise the gel band of
the appropriate size and we process
those with a kyochon mini mini Aleut gel
extraction kit and once we have alluded
that it's in a typically small volume
anywhere between 11 and 30 microliters
we will take that gel extract and a
portion of that will be run in a cycle
sequencing reaction we use the beckman
coulter genome lab g exp so we use the
beckman coulter sequencing chemistry in
order to do our sequencing reactions and
that uses at what they call a dtcs Quick
Start Kit such as die terminator cycle
sequencing and essentially you are
taking a master mick because you're
adding in a primer and then you add in
your amplicon and run a cycle sequencing
reaction on that when that's completed
we use a kyochon die x kit in order to
remove the unincorporated nucleotides
and then place that in a speed back
until it's dried within that quick start
kit there is an SLS solution which is
essentially formamide and that sample is
then resuspended in the form of mine put
into a 96-well plate and I drop a
mineral oil is added and the beauty of
the beckman coulter genome lab g exp to
me is the onboard denaturation you put
your plate on the sequencer and it does
everything else for you thereafter so
denaturation and capillary
electrophoresis we then will export the
sequences from the genome lab de XP and
to the chi agency LLC main software
program will trim the sequences and
create consensus sequences if we were
able to get both forward and reverse
sequences and those consensus sequences
are then submitted to ncbi's blast where
we can determine what we have and what's
the highest identity to so moving on to
slide 12 just to give you an idea of the
different pathogens that we are able
to look at we have runs thus far up
until September first about 3500
molecular tests this year a vast
majority are two respiratory pathogens
like add new virus influenza
mycobacteria I'll be talking about here
shortly parrot influenza viruses we have
a phase for para influenza viruses one
two three and four RSV staph and strep
we have some stds some GI vector borne
pathogens like rickettsia which i'll be
talking about shortly as well as well as
others that don't fall neatly in some of
these categories like nro viruses and
troffer remal apply we also have a very
nice broad range 16s rrna that we can
use to try to identify cases where we
aren't particularly sure what specific
pathogen might be in the specimen but it
looks like it's bacterial in nature
moving on to slide 13 one of the
components of the work that we do here
in the infectious diseases pathology
branches look and unexplained deaths and
we cooperate with a couple of different
states on unexplained death
investigations so one state that we have
a close relationship with here is
Minnesota and this case then i'm going
to present to you came from there this
is a one week old female who was found
deceased in their bassinet at autopsy
the medical examiner found myocarditis
but very little else in the tissues and
the heart tissues did indeed demonstrate
a marked inflammation there were
lymphocytes some histiocytes as well as
neutrophils but the gram stains were
negative implying that this was a viral
infection immunohistochemistry was
requested and a pan enterovirus
immunohistochemistry was performed and
that antibody cross reacts with many
viruses including the NRO viruses so at
that point molecular testing was
requested and this particular assay
isn't a conventional rt-pcr SI and
primers recognize the most common
enterovirus group species and this
targets to 5 prime
see our of the virus so on the right
hand side of the slide you can see an
image of the gel this is a 231 base pair
fragment you can see the positive
control and no template control or water
control and then the positive case on
the right the band from the positive
case was then excised from the gel and
if we go to the next slide the genome
lab GXP data are shown here you can see
on the top the actual sequence data and
the raw data on the bottom now if we
take the sequence data and we export it
into CLC or we trimmed it up a bit and
then sent that through the NCBI blast I
got a very decent hit in terms of the
way enterovirus is go i 96 / 98% hit to
human coxsackievirus be five and we
additionally shared this specimen with
the picornavirus group here at CDC and
they were able to indeed confirm that
this was a kaka Becky b5 so moving on to
another unexplained death investigation
that we did this is a 24 year old male
who was a cruise line employee and they
had spent 16 weeks on the Eastern
Western Caribbean route and then went to
Indonesia for eight weeks after the ship
docked they had had a six-month history
of diarrhea and when they returned for
work within two hours they had diarrhea
high fever and vomiting they ended up
having to be transported to the hospital
off of the ship and died two days later
the hospital tests for strep flu malaria
and methicillin-resistant Staph aureus
were all negative so they sent liver
respiratory tissues kidney brain heart
and GI tissues here to the infectious
diseases pathology branch the
immunohistochemistry for dengue virus
was performed it was negative and
another rule out was influenza so I
performed rt-pcr on the specimen and it
was also negative however the
conventional rt-pcr for dengi was indeed
positive
quickly for dengue virus 3 so these are
the kinds of things that we look look
for here in the infectious diseases
pathology branch now one of the things
that we have seen a lot recently is the
outbreak with Zika virus so on slide 16
you'll see a specimen that came in as a
suspected zika case it was an infant
born with microcephaly in March and the
mother had a history of travel to panama
during their first trimester however the
Zika immunohistochemistry and rt-pcr
were all negative there were gram
positive cocci noted on a Gram stain so
pcr for streptococcus was requested and
that particular assay looks at these
streptococcus 16s rrna and again you can
see the data here on the slide where we
have a very nice sequence data and very
interestingly that was a perfect match
to streptococcus agalactiae a group b
strep we do also test for zika as i
mentioned and just to briefly mention it
it is a conventional rt-pcr to the NS
five gene and it dif differentiates the
asian from the African serotypes by
Sanger sequencing and you can see by
this picture it's a very short fragment
that we're able to sequence but we are
indeed able to get very nice sequence
data from these cases so moving on to
slide 18 more outbreak investigations
that we look at include mycobacteria and
a lot of these specimens are very
important in the fact that it's
necessary to distinguish mycobacterium
tuberculosis from other types of
mycobacteria because the treatments do
differ and with mycobacteria
tuberculosis there are several drugs
which are possible drugs that are
resistant are found to be resistant and
it's very important men for treatment of
the individual as well as treatment for
contacts
the case that I'm showing here on slide
18 is actually a fatal case and they
died from acute renal failure in
California and 2015 at the time of their
death there was no clinical suspicion of
mycobacterium tuberculosis they were a
64 year old male had low blood pressure
again acute renal failure at the gastric
pain and weight loss bronchoalveolar
lavage was performed and the acid-fast
bacilli stain on the smear of that was
negative as was the culture they were
not in the hospital for long and
unfortunately died quickly at autopsy
there were many histopathological
features of disseminated tuberculosis in
the lung liver and spleen that were
shown so you can understand that there
were many concerns than for
drug-resistant tuberculosis so there
were no other specimens available except
for the formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
autopsy tissues so we took those and
performed the H and E stains as you can
see on the left on the slide there's
granulomatous inflammation as well as
necrosis in the pulmonary parenchyma and
on the right and acid-fast bacilli stain
which is a zeal nelson stain is showing
in the little purple dots the acid-fast
bacilli the immunohistochemistry shown
on the bottom and you can see the red
darker staining those are mycobacterial
antigens in the granule illness when the
molecular pathology team did their
handiwork mycobacterium tuberculosis was
indeed identified by pcr and we work
very closely on mycobacteria cases with
the mycobacteria group here at CDC and
they do all of the multidrug resistance
testing so fortunately this was a case
that was not drug-resistant if we move
on to the next slide slide 19 we are
looking at a case where they were trying
to determine whether this was
tuberculosis or not again it was a fatal
case due to pulmonary failure in
Delaware of 2013 a 61 year old who died
suddenly during deployment to
Afghanistan after coughing of blood
they'd had a previous history of
carcinoma a few
prior at autopsy there were cavity lung
lesions pulmonary hemorrhage so there
was a concern at that point for
drug-resistant TB especially because he
had 22 contacts in four different states
as well as overseas fortunately this one
turned out to be a case of mycobacterium
avium complex species by pcr and
therefore the tuberculosis was ruled out
another very similar instance this one
where we got a very minut specimen as
you can see on the on the bottom of the
slide how small that tissue specimen was
this is from Ohio in 2013 it was an 18
18 year old woman who had nodular
Hodgkin's disease so they were indeed
immunocompromised they had multiple
lesions in the spleen and a core biopsy
revealed a few acid-fast bacilli so the
question at this point is do they
continue with chemotherapy or do they
undergo tuberculosis treatment well the
cultures from mycobacteria were negative
and the qantas Iran test for
mycobacteria tuberculosis was negative
so special stains and
immunohistochemistry were performed here
in IDP be and those were negative using
the FFPE tissues however the molecular
group was able to perform PCR and did
get a positive and again it was a
mycobacterium avium complex species and
they were able to then continue on with
their chemotherapy moving on to slide 20
this is a bit of an outbreak have
started out with a single case and then
quickly became an outbreak in New York
and New York City actually it started
with an 81 year old Chinese women who
had subcutaneous nodules on the hand and
dorsal wrist and they had handled raw
fish for cooking so the question was is
this Mycobacterium marinum or another
non-tuberculous mycobacteria it was
culture negative for bacteria and fungi
and it was indeed positive by pcr for
mycobacterium marinum mariah
subsequently more cases were then
identified a chinese women who handled
live or raw fish and we ended up getting
24 cases evaluated here
just diseases pathology branch so moving
on to slide 21 I'm going to move into
how some of our work translates into
projects that we work on these
particular slides next are going to be
talking about spotted fever group
rickettsia these are obligate Lee
intracellular gram-negative bacteria and
are spread by vectors including fleas
ticks and mites there are nine named
species endemic in the United States but
three are really the root cause of
rickettsia infections in the United
States so rickettsia rickettsii which
causes Rocky Mountain spotted fever or
are MSF rickettsia Parker I which causes
rickettsia Parker eric etsy OSIS and
rickettsia Acker I which causes
rickettsia talks on this slide you can
also see a picture of a yolk sac that
they use to grow rickettsia rickettsii
and all the little dark purple dots are
the rickettsia rickettsii in the yolk
sac moving on to slide 22 typically
these specimens that we use for
rickettsia assessment our skin biopsies
so you can imagine they're very small
tissue specimens so the nice thing about
having an ffpe tissue block like this is
we can do a lot of different tests but
at the same time because there's not a
lot of tissue while we may have five
tests available we only have enough
tissue for three so the number of tests
that can be performed as limited as I
mentioned before we have some of those
drawbacks with ffpe tissues with
oxidation and formal affixation but
they're great for shipping you don't
have to refrigerate them they're not
infectious so if we move on to slide 23
just a little bit of background about
Rocky Mountain spotted fever it's a
rather nasty disease with a pretty high
fatality rate if there's no treatment
you can see the worst being in the
Bitterroot Valley of Montana which had a
sixty-three percent case fatality rate
in the early nineteen hundreds one of
the more recent in 2002 to 2004 there
was an outbreak in White Mountain
Arizona where it had a case fatality
rate of twelve percent
moving on to slide 24 this just shows
the incidence of rickettsia rickettsii
throughout the united states and you can
see that the belt in the middle of the
united states where the highest
incidence occurs but there are many
areas throughout the united states that
are affected by Rocky Mountain spotted
fever moving on to the next slide by 25
there are three different ticks that
transmit Rocky Mountain spotted fever
here in the United States pretty much
every aspect of the continental United
States is affected by one tick or other
that can spread this disease in slide 26
the symptoms of Rocky Mountain spotted
fever quite severe a very high fever
headache nausea vomiting muscle aches
and a rash that may take three to five
days of Pete to appear if it appears at
all one of the differentiating factors
with Rocky Mountain spotted fever is you
do not get an F scar at the site of
ticket a CH Minh tile show you some
pictures of s cars here in a few moments
the bacteria in this case localize and
multiply in the endothelial cells of the
small and medium sized blood vessels so
that you end up getting vasculitis which
is the cause of the rash but you you
will get vasculitis systemically moving
on to slide 27 it's a rare disease and
it's missed quite often on initial
evaluation in sixty to eighty five
percent of the time because it's a
tick-borne the disease it's seasonal so
ninety percent of the cases are found
between April in September and sixty to
seventy percent of the people will will
remember a recent tick bite the problem
with this disease though is that it's
rapidly progressive and you will be
severely ill within four to five days
maybe about the same time that that rash
is starting to appear if it is shows at
all and the therapeutic window for the
best outcome is really narrow it's
really within those first five days most
of the deaths when they occur occur
within seven to nine days after onset
it's just miraculously fast sadly fast
so untreated disease has very
devastating consequences moving on to
the next slide slide 28 and show
the rash of a patient with Rocky
Mountain spotted fever as it compares to
rickettsia Parker I rickettsii OSIS and
you may say well what's what's the
differentiating factor here that's the
issue there is no differential
differentiating factor you cannot tell
the difference between these two rashes
so all you can say that it looks like a
rickettsial disease or it might actually
look like many other types of diseases
too as we'll discuss in a few moments on
slide 29 then rickettsia parkerich etsy
OSIS is found more in the Gulf Coast
area of the United States southern parts
of the United States and it is
oftentimes associated with an S car and
that's what's shown on the bottom right
of this slide is a picture of an S car
that also looks like many other things
as you can imagine I'll show another
slide in a little bit that will discuss
that so if there is no esk are present
as happens sometimes you can see on
slide 30 the clinical features that
compare the Rocky Mountain spotted fever
with rickettsia Parker eric etsy OSIS
are quite similar both have fever both
have headache both have maculopapular
rash in many of the instances so again
it's very difficult to discern Rocky
Mountain spotted fever from rickettsia
Parker I rickettsii Oh Sees based on
clinical features now one of the biggest
things that you'll notice is the very
last line rickettsia Parker Eric ezio
sees has resulted in zero deaths thus
far where I was Rocky Mountain spotted
fever in this particular sample set I
always a seven percent death rate
treatment is the same for both
doxycycline so it's one of those
situations where you would rather treat
somebody than not but it is helpful to
know which they have as you know our MSF
is so much more severe the third
rickettsia locks that we see here in the
United States is predominantly an urban
disease that's transmitted by mice that
are found mites that are found on mice
the pathogen occurs on several different
continents but the disease is almost
never described beyond New York City in
fact greater than ninety-nine percent of
the u.s. cases are from New York City
but we have identified cases in
Baltimore
Austin Trenton New York and Philadelphia
it's relatively mild compared to other
rickettsial diseases hasn't been studied
extensively except for about sixty five
years ago cases occur year-round and
often family clusters are reported
people who are living in the same
household having that same exposure you
will see it in related family members
it's not a nationally notifiable disease
but in New York City it is indeed
reportable the majority of New York City
cases originated in Manhattan on the
Upper West End as well as the Bronx and
here in IDP be we see three to five
cases each year so on slide 32 a little
bit more about rickettsia pox
presentation there is an S car at the
primary inoculation site that's
described in 83 to a hundred percent of
the patients generally on the extremity
some of them even have multiples and it
may persist from for three to four weeks
and form a small scar there is also a
rash similar to what you would see in
rickettsia park or i work at cfcs a
Rocky Mountain spotted fever and it
follows the onset of fever by one to
four days there are small popular
vesicles they're relatively sparse and
painless they're found on the
extremities trunk and face but rarely on
the palms and soles and the severity of
the rash is not necessarily indicative
of how severe the illness is there are
also Lygia lesions that are found on the
mucosa on the tongue the evil is soft
palate that happens in seventeen to
twenty six percent of cases and there
are small erosion zor vesicles there
that appear early in the disease course
and are typically short-lived
systemically and rickettsia pox on slide
33 you'll see that there is a fever and
headache and muscle aches within two to
seven days after the appearance of the S
car and the fever is generally less
severe than the other well recognized
for kenzie Oh Sees also you will find
conjunctivitis pharyngitis nausea and
vomiting and if untreated the disease
persists for seven to ten days but it's
relatively mild compared to the other
raquet cocs and usually resolves on its
own however hepatitis
photophobia and nuchal rigidity has been
recorded so if we look at slide 34 this
is a slide comparing rashes of different
types of diseases you can see rocky
mountain spotted fever on the upper left
rat-bite fever on the lower left a
meningioma samia on the upper right and
katniss atopica sepsis on the lower
right they all look very similar which
is why it's very nice to have a species
specific diagnosis to know which
particular pathogen you're truly looking
at in these instances and again if we
look at slide 35 the S car from our kept
seal pox or rickettsia park or
iantrickett COCs look very similar to
that of say African tick bite fever or
even a brown recluse bite so it's a very
important to be able to distinguish
exactly what pathogen we're working with
if it's indeed an infectious agent so
slide 36 shows the immunohistochemistry
of these three rickettsia species and
again notably there's nothing really
notable to distinguish these it they all
look very similar so that's where
molecular pathology and pcr really come
in handy so an IDP be historically we
have used two different pcrs the first
is to be 17 kill adult and antigen
jeaneth present in all spotted fever
group rickettsia it's a nested pcr so it
is a bit timely it produces a PCR
product of 247 base pairs in the primary
and 218 base pairs in the nested and you
can sequence the amplicon and it'll
essentially just tell you it's
rickettsia it's not going to tell you
any species specific information so when
we can we would then do PCR to the UMP a
gene that's present in many of the
spotted favor group rickettsia but not
in all of them so it's lacking in
rickettsia australis rickettsia
helvetica rickettsia Acura and
rickettsia belly I again it's a nested
pcr so it does take some time but the
problem with this assay well we get very
nice amplicons that provide good species
data they're very
so if you have a very fragmented sample
you're not going to get a positive that
you can actually sequence so one of the
things that were was really a goal here
for us to be able to identify more cases
was to develop some real-time pcr assays
when those conventional assays failed us
so we have two different assays the
first just detects rickettsia species
it's a small 74 base pair product and it
detects all spotted fever as well as a
typhus group rickettsia except for
rickettsia belly I its to the citrate
synthase gene and this is a published SI
by Stennis that came out in 2005 one of
the things that I worked though to do
was to create one assay to the aunt bee
gene of rickettsia occur I which is 144
base pair product and I teamed that with
a couple of published essays one to the
aunt v gene of rickettsia Parker I and
96 base pair products and one specific
to hypothetical protein gene of
rickettsia rickettsii in order to create
a triplex real-time pcr assay and in
with this essay we were able to
determine a species specific diagnosis
in very fragmented samples 12 cases of
Rocky Mountain spotted fever have been
detected since this essay has started to
be utilized seven cases over ketsia Park
arrived akechi OSIS 11 cases of her kept
sealed talks and one case of rickettsia
Parker I that was actually determined to
be rickettsia accra which is very
interesting so with that slide 39 I
would like to just thank all of you for
your your kind attention and my
supervisor Julie Batna gar for all of
her assistance with the presentation as
a couple of slides that she provided as
well as her general guidance from day to
day Chris paddock is my former
supervisor he's in the rickettsia you
know sees branch now who's been a
wonderful mentor and
helped a lot with the rickettsia studies
and getting those under way as well as
our branch chief sharif sake so if you
would like to contact me I did list my
email and phone numbers there and if you
would like any information from the CDC
we do have the address and the telephone
number for CDC info listed on this
particular slide if you are interested
in submitting specimens to the
infectious diseases pathology branch we
do require prior consultation and we
have all of that information listed on
our website if they could show you the
website link you may contact us there
and there's lots of information on what
types of specimens that you can submit
and the types of testing that we can
perform so with that I thank you all and
I'll open it up for questions excellent
presentation dr. Denison thank you for
bringing that information to us before
we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many as we can our first
question is what is the nucleic after
the mountain range typically you collect
from FFPE samples and how much do you
use Sanger sequencing well we we have
found over the years at least with using
nana drop that is a little hard to
determine the concentrations of these
they're very small amounts typically in
the nanogram you know as some of them
that we've used as been as low as an
anagram maybe ten nanograms per
microliter but that is it's hard to
exactly say because we will often find
that due to the nature of formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue there are a lot
of inhibitors in there so at least the
value that the nanodrop gives us is kind
of false so those are typically hard to
determine for sure what we typically do
when we're running our reactions is we
we have a base amount that we will use
we will use two and a half microliters
and it
five microliter PCR reaction or five
microliters in a 50 micro litre reaction
of our nucleic acid and all of that then
we'll get run on our a gross jail when
we've completed the PCR and the entire
amplicon men will be excised and
extracted into a small enough volume
that we can depending on whether we're
just going to use a single primer for
sequencing or if we're going to use both
the forward and reverse primer for
sequencing it will give us just enough
in order to perform the Sanger
sequencing do you perform molecular
testing on fungal or yeast infection and
how would you screen for fungal
infection we do not do that ourselves as
I mentioned we collaborate a lot with
the SMEs here at CDC so with fungal
specimens or suspected fungal specimens
if we see something that suggested is
that on the 80s or special stains will
send that to the my cot x division and
we essentially just send them scrolls
and they have their own extraction
methods and pcrs that they will do to
help us out with that if you ever
encounter new strains or species that
are not found in the ncbi database and
what actions do you take to confirm new
species or strings because of the nature
of the assays in the way that we run
them we typically are running something
that's specific to a certain pathogen or
a group of pathogens say a pan species
assay so if we are getting an amplicon
we're typically going to get a hit in
the ncbi blast database it's a matter of
identity how high the identity is if we
have something that's seemingly
different enough and again it depends on
which particular agent we're talking
about you know with with strep some of
those can have just a one percent
difference between them and those can be
difficult to discern from one another
but with nro viruses there can be a
somewhat broader range as something
that's ninety-six percent identity is
too
indeed an enterovirus so again that kind
of depends and if we have any questions
based on the sequencing data that we get
will collaborate with the SME group here
at CDC will provide them extracts and
then work back and forth to try to
figure out exactly what it is that we
are dealing with performing microbiology
but using molecular methods can fiji MBS
perform these tests i'm not familiar
with CG MBS while we're waiting for more
questions to come in I would like to
once again shank dr. Denison for her
presentation another question for you um
in a normal day in the CDC lab how many
samples are being processed and how
about when is a large outbreak so that
again you know very zoom with what's
going on there in our lab on a typical
non outbreak day we probably would get
maybe five cases in and in terms of the
molecular side you know a case may
constitute just a single block or it may
constitute a hundred blocks from there
you know it depends on how many are
requested for testing you know we may
see 10 or 15 requests per week in a non
outbreak situation right now with the
Zika outbreak our numbers are much
higher so we're probably performing
about 60 maybe extractions per week just
for phenyl chloroform extracted RNA
again that depends on how many cases we
get in per week which varies highly
during the influenza outbreak in 2009 we
were seeing probably a similar number
come
and so you know is we were definitely
busy considering that these extractions
are a two-day process it's a you know a
time Lisa it takes it takes a fair bit
of time in order to get these and then
sadly we only get a minut quantity of
nucleic acid in the end so our number of
tests is limited as well
and for the last question I'd like to
clarify when performing microbiology but
using molecular methods can clinical
genetic molecular biologists scientists
perform these tests I would imagine so
yeah any the most of these a lot of
these are published that we use either
we will we will take something from
another SME group here at CDC and adapt
it to our specimens but they're they're
very typically just standard pcr rxns
standard sequencing reactions that I
think you know any molecular biologist
could perform okay and in the next
question on TX is the first term use so
I'm going to assume it means Texas so
Texas doesn't have for catia causing
kicks how does the CDC multi-color
pathology manage other subtropical
infectious diseases that make it in
through South America travels well you
know typically we rely on the clinicians
and and the clinical information that
they provide to us so we will you know
if there's a suspected case of you know
rickettsia from another country say we
hope that the clinician is able to get
trouble information travel history from
the patient and you know we rely a lot
on that especially for the rickettsia
cases for other things you know again we
rely on the local public health
departments that will do surveillance in
particular areas say you know Florida's
doing surveillance for Zika and dengue
I'm sure Texas was probably doing a lot
of the same types of things in mosquito
populations and then you know as they're
seeing patients come in i'm sure that
these things are in the minds of the
clinicians and it's only you know when
the clinicians have issues that they
have trouble diagnosing these or if they
want us a specific confirmation that
those specimens will then
come to us here in the infectious
diseases pathology branch which company
makes the CDC's main software for
consensus sequence assembly the CLC
program that is used is made by kyochon
yeah and again while we're waiting for
additional questions to come in i would
like to once again thank you dr. Denison
for your presentation do you have any
final comments I am just so glad to be
able to participate in this it's been an
interesting experience I wish the
webinar web camera would have worked
that would have been a definite nice
added touch to it but I definitely
appreciate the opportunity and I hope
that this has raised some awareness as
to what we do and if there's anything
that we can do to help you know the
public health professionals out there we
would just we'd love to offer our
assistance well thank you and I would
also like to thank our sponsor science
for making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 8 2016 you'll receive
an email from us alerting you when it's
available for on-demand viewing and
posted on lab routes comm you are
welcome to forward this announcement to
any colleagues are unable to join in
today we thank you for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast and
see you next time thank you